اخبارنا الدكتور عبد الله رضيعه والفريق
الطبي كامل انه وضعهم مستقر والحمد لله
وانهم بصحه جيده وان شاء الله بس منتظرين
للافارقه وشكر جزيل الدكتور عبد الله
الربيع ولطاقم الطبي كاملا وشكري وامتناني
الى الملك
والى الملك سلمان والى ولي عهده الامين
محمد بن سلمان والى الشعب السعودي كافه
الذي تفاعل معنا شكرا جزيلا
مشاهدينا من مستشفى الملك عبد الله
التخصصي للاطفال بوزاره الحرس الوطني
بالرياض هاني صياد مراسل العربيه هذه يعني
كيف يمكن الحديث عن وضع الطفلين علي وعمر
بعد نجاح عمليات الفصل وضعهم الصحي وكل
التفاصيل معك
نعم اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدي قناه العربيه
مره اخرى عمر وعلي هما حالتهما الصحيه
الان جيده بحسب حديث اكادر الطبيه الموجود
هنا في مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض وتحديدا في وزاره
التابع لوزاره الحرس الوطني طبعا هما في
تحت التخدير الان ما زال هذه غرفه همم علي
وهو الان يتم الاشراف عليهم من قبل كادر
الطبي وكذلك الغرفه المجاوره له وهي لغرفه
لعمر وايضا يتم مراقبه همم حاله عمر وعلي
من خلال الكادر الطبي وكذلك من خلال
التقنيات الحديثه الموفره هنا في المستشفى
ولكن بشكل طبي دقيق سوف نتحدث مع الدكتوره
هاله العالم وهي استشاريه عنايه مركزه
للاطفال تفضل لنا الدكتور ونتحدث اليوم عن
حاله الحاله الان لعمر وعلي او علي وعمر
خاصه في ظل وضعهما الان في حاله التخدير
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اللهم صل
وسلم وبارك على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
وسلم
حاله الطفلين الحمد لله مستقره
استلمنا الطفل الطفلين
حوالي ثلاث ساعات
والمؤشرات الحيويه مطمئنه همم اي اختلاف
في المؤشرات الحيويه في اول ثلاثه ساعات
همم تعتبر طبيعيه ومقبوله ويتم التعامل مع
الارتفاع دقات القلب او ضغط همم الدم وكذا
عن طريق المراقبه وعن طريق همم اللي هو
تظبيط الادويه المناسبه الدكتور الاخر في
حاله اتفاقه علي وعمر من التقدير الان هل
هناك مده معينه من عمليه استفاده قام سوف
يتم استمرار عمليه تقديم ما حتى وصول الى
نقطه معينه طبيه مثلا طبعا احنا اي طفل
بعد عمليه طويله يستفيق همم يعني يبدا
بالافاقه بعد العمليه هذا مؤشر جيد جدا
جدا همم ولكن احنا نحبد ان احنا نعطيهم
الجرعات اللي هي المهدئه والمسكنه للالم
حتى يعني همم
يمر عليهم اكثر من 12 ساعه او 24 ساعه همم
لانه العمليه كبيره ومؤلمه فهذا يؤثر كذلك
اذا كان في الم وما سيطرنا عليه ويؤثر على
المؤشرات الحيويه
24 ساعه هي الحاله الطبيه الطبيعيه اللي
همم استفاقه عمر علي همم الاستفاق تمت
الحمد لله نعم يعني عندك حليب بدا يتحرك
الان هو بيتحرك لكن ايوه نتعامل مع ال همم
الحاله الان بان احنا نعطي له اللي هو
جرعات مناسبه بحيث انه نرجع وينام لانه
همم اهم شيء السيطره على قلم وعدم التوتر
في اول همم يعني 12 ساعه نقول من العمليه
الى 24 ساعه ومن ثم تدريجيا نخفف اللي هو
المسكنات وال- همم
غرفه ونشاهد ايضا عمليه الاستفاده اذا كان
لدي وقت لو 30 ثانيه هذه هي غرفه علي
والان تم استفقته بشكل تدريجي طبعا بخلاف
اخيه عمر طبعا هناك طبعا كما ذكرت
الدكتوره هاله ان هناك مسكنات تعطى للحاله
علي في همم احتياجه لي اذا لزم الامر في
احتياجه وكذلك للمسكنات وكذلك لاستمرار
عمليه تخدير التدريجي ولكن هو استفاق بشكل
كامل ويتم متابعه حالته طبعا الامر المهم
بالنسبه للطفلين علي وعمر ان العلامات
الحيويه خلال الثلاث ساعات الماضيه بعد
وصولهم ده
غرفته ما هي سليمه وصحيه وجيده وذلك من
خلال التقنيات التي يتم متابعتها والاجهزه
الطبيه الموجوده اضافه الى الكادر الطبيه
الموجود ايضا هنا في مستشفى الملك عبد
الله التخصصي في وزاره الحرس الوطني في
العاصمه السعوديه
الرياضي الذي واكب هذه العمليه وسهم
بنجاحها وشكر خاص ايضا لك على مواكبه هذه
العمليه لاكثر من اثنتي عشر ساعه طيلت
يعني السعاده الماضيه شكرا لك مراسل
العربيه هذه الصبيان على هذه الشهود